You know,
I used to think that I knew it all.
But all I did was walk into my own arrogant wall.
I traded good character for pride.
And truth was lost on the other side.
I wanted to live selfishly for the world.
With all its sin.
That's what I thought would make me successful, and win.
But it did not.   And I slowly felt my inner man rot.
I chased after money, alcohol, and girls with all my fleshly might.
Why not?
I was young and wanted to
feel the life of the night.
They say that money makes
the world go round and round.
But they don't tell you that
evil lurks in the background.
You see, I thought I was invincible.
The master of my own life.
But when truth set me free, I
realized I was just another low life.
One day I suddenly got a phone
call that would forever change me.
A new path that would finally make me free.
But it came at a great cost as it
usually does to those who are lost.
My father's voice came
trembling through the phone.
With pain, telling me I need
to come home with the airplane.
You see, my second brother Etienne is about to
die and he asked me to come and say goodbye.
I flew back home finding myself
next to him on the hospital bed.
I see my brother lifeless.
He's dead.
Why God?
Why did you take another brother from me?
This can't be real.
Please make him alive again.
That was my plea.
And suddenly God spoke directly to my soul
Saying I was on a dangerous roll.
Daniel, your brother is saved here with Me.
But if you died, in hell you would be.
This is your wake-up call.
To look the truth of life in the eye
and decide where you want to end up when you die.
He showed me the truth of death and life.
And urged me to take a deeper breath.
I took your brother because he was ready
and deep down, you know that already.
Stop running away from Me and make your choice.
The devil or Me.
And say it with your voice.
Daniel, you're arrogant and wasting your short life.
You never even think about the afterlife.
He called me out for my arrogance and
showed me the lack of my significance.
I have always been there protecting you and
your small brain does not even have a clue.
With His loving voice I began to see
thetruth that had always been around me.
Even though, you know for a fact, I
am real growing up the way you did
with your father full of spiritual zeal.
You know, I am your Creator who loves you
and you know that's true.
It's time.
What do you say?
You've been walking in the
dark for too long as a stray.
Come home to Me.
So I can make you whole.
And save your eternal soul.
Alright, OK God, but I don't
want a man-made religion.
I want you.
I can now feel your love and
I just want to be close to you.
Like glue.
Please change me even if you have to use the rod.
Please forgive me for all my sins.
Because I've been using them like skins.
I can see the evil within me and
only with you can I be truly free.
That is the day my whole life changed.
By God, it was arranged.
He made me a new creation so
that I can be saved from damnation.
And I will see my brothers again.
From heaven, that is only
some of what I will gain.
You see, I'm now a new creation that's free
because of His spirit that is within me.
He freed me from sin, death, and pain.
And now I'm living a life that's truly sane.
I was blind but now I see.
Thank you God for saving me.
And making me the person that
I was always meant to be.